being the only child growing up uh
you know my father being a heroin act
and everything
i only live and learn from my father my
father was always a workaholic and
but as far as you know
having little symptoms of allergies
whatever not and get shots behind my
back and etc etc
and allergic to you know certain kind of
plants and
guacamole and get shots every week the
needles were not even
like even bothering me at all like okay
cool like oh you don't cry like okay
cool
now whatever but my father as a techato
i learned from him i'm not proud of it
but i experience of
heroin was first struggle twice at 12
years old
it only makes it to only be worse never
better as far as yeah you get a little
family a little money in your pocket
yeah you know do a little thing but
don't get caught up in the game
you know but making my money in my
neighborhood
hey lo loco relax hold me thank you
relax and
why you guys yeah i saw your rock i saw
my heroine what's what's wrong with that
when they smell the primos and cocoa
puffs i'm doing a shot what's wrong with
that
but the way i do my shot i just could
never do enough because what just a
little bit at a young age
boom what an idiot throw me in the tub
25 25 35 minutes later wake up [ __ ]
cold as [ __ ] out of the shower
what's up mommy here's your don't forget
how many [ __ ] pen there
oops i did it again huh well you know at
12
13 14 15 and 17.
oh dean on heroin never once went to the
hospital on the shower
because why my homies are on parole you
know i'm gonna come down on one for you
i'm gonna go i ain't gonna jump for your
ass homie you know get together homie
what's up i mean
what can i say you know uh it's an
experience to
live and tell or rest in peace spooky
homes right right in the grave you know
i believe in this disease of addiction
that we go through
is either you are to be foretold to be
stand tall and stand strong for this
addition that you accomplished
or breath take and say i'll be with you
man and he was a good man but it's
[ __ ] up that the drugs took over him
and died but as far as i got older
into a teenager you know crystal
and heroin is like a chase the dragon
[ __ ]
it only gets better never gets worse it
only gets better as one drug leads to
another it says
and people look at me like are you
stupid hey am i
being a hypocrite amongst anyone doing
their drug no
am i tripping you look at the window
stop being paranoid you over here
trying to fix them they can't be fixed
and you what are you drawing what do you
i mean
people all you have a play role but what
i'm trying to tell you is that when i do
my thing
and you guys see me with my can and my
little lighter what
let me enjoy my [ __ ] man [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] you know but
i could never enjoy it because what i
think is enough is never enough because
what
one is too many and a thousand never
enough and when i do the injection
the heat just comes quick boom
[ __ ] ben what's up i don't hear a
word they say until i wake up
25 minutes later in the water what is
wrong with me
now what is wrong with me i said you
know it ain't my time
when is your time oh i mean what do i
want to see within myself at the age i
am 41 years old
spokes in a wheelchair spooks has one
leg
suppose has one eye oh he has a hey how
are you doing
i mean what is it you want to be
resembled as a as
a demonstration for society that what
you've been through to tell a tale
you lost your legs over what your
addiction
wow yeah some have worse than others
okay you know uh when i think that
you know uh odin and go in the hospital
and then you uh happen just to
just do crystal by itself and to the
extreme of just beyond
like damn what's really going on with
this guy man
smoking balls doing scarface lines
are you satisfied never enough you want
to go home and
your girl wants to uh take off where are
you going baby
she's crying you know you're with the
homies there you go again
you want to save her you have to save
jump in the car she's taking off she's
hitting me hitting me hitting me
it never gets better when it gets worse
as far as something on my chest it's
like getting so tight
all of a sudden i cramp in my my mouth
my tongue is going back
i pinch it oh now you wanna play games
she said what's wrong with you and i
went through convulsions holding my
tongue
oh my god boom is her hospital bell
flower
as far as she talked to the nurse my
mom's having a seizure they put me into
the room
that's before the doctor was like you
know put a little wooden thing in my
mouth and i swallowed my tongue
to give me a shot so i just caught my
heartbeat down or whatever was going
inside my body because my body was going
too extreme crazy
do you have a seizure like that and
before i they're going to give me a shot
i hit minute 15 seconds cold blue
electricity three times first time
nothing second time nothing third time
got my heart beat back
i wake up 25 minutes later my eyes are
burning red and fire my girl's crying on
my arm
you gotta stop what do i say it's gonna
be okay
[ __ ] spooky sorry like you know like
yeah he has it all day he
is he and
you figure out of the hospital after
experience almost a death
does that wake up i figure i hope so
i wish i could tell you the same thing
that you would think that it would be
the best but it's not
it only gets worse as far as my actions
for no license no registration yeah okay
do some time whatever little stack on
the hand
you know i uh
go do my time i come back and then the
my leg drives a volvo as long as i a
tank car to safe and sounding
seven days at a warehouse work at seven
eight or seven in the morning i don't
sleep
for seven days every time i go home this
company every time i go home there's
people in the room every time you know
there's like
what can i say you know i mean what can
i say i'm there playing my playstation
eating my ice cream
you know do i sleep no does she care no
i gotta go to work though gotta work
don't trip i'll be back
go to work seven nights in the morning
seven days i go
friday night come home saturday morning
two minutes away from pika rivero by
smith park from my house
and the little duplex right there my
body shut down man my body shut down
damn it shut down to the
cars driving 50-60 miles an hour no
seatbelt
still 12 boots on damn oil burning right
here my flannel
hit the dancing on the bridge boom 50 to
60 miles an hour
the only thing was the ceiling how the
car
impact that car was like whoever was in
the shotgun would be like harmonica
hormonal
everything crushed like oh [ __ ] did i
see anything
the only thing with the steering wheel
came so rapidly if
it twisted my wrist ah
that's it that's it that's all i felt
like
oh and then i didn't hear no ambulance
they use the jaws of life to open the
car door i didn't hear no metal open
door
they sent a helicopter on the playground
i didn't even [ __ ] film my first
helicopter ride how did you get feel
[ __ ]
i didn't hear no sirens i didn't hear no
people talking hey we got him we got we
gotta i didn't hear
nothing what a [ __ ] trip
i wake up five days later in a coma
five days later my mom and my auntie
were there to visit me every day
and boy what the eyes
see from a mother figure you know moms
moms moms never lie to you mijo
we watched you and you were laying down
like you were like this
like you were talking to somebody or
there's something going on but
really mom she was yes your lips are
just
was like sleep talking you weren't
saying nothing but you
wow what do you what what do you want to
call that
um like a sign well deeper than that
reality deeper than that would you say
that's how your higher power is going to
give you a sign
hell yeah okay what did you see oh wow
death is is it's no joke
you know god has you here for a reason
don't ask me why don't ask me how but
just a [ __ ] bro that just goes
out and the outside of the heads is like
an orange reddish and you keep rubbing
your eyes
hey is anyone there and you just want to
like i just barely see the face you just
keep looking but you can't see the face
but the outside of the head is just man
[ __ ]
a lot of a lot of people
a lot of people you see but the one
thing that uh
is what the [ __ ] is that noise in the
bible it says for the sufferings of pain
being in hell
let's say you grind their teeth but
they're dead
exactly they ain't got no teeth their
gums their gums and
everyone's doing it
oh my god that's like damn
chalkboard skill little chills yeah
everyone's doing it like
it's like what the hell is that
everyone's [ __ ]
suffering and that little [ __ ]
lighthouse way over there just coming
and the lighthouse hits me i wake up
i see a light blue [ __ ] uh roof like
[ __ ] up my head
look down my [ __ ] body okay quick
body check left leg good
right leg good right arm good left back
ah it was all white
and i look at like where the [ __ ] am i
at and that guy goes you're in the
hospital i look at him like
okay good who the [ __ ] did i hit what am
i here
i mean i didn't know [ __ ] here comes the
nurse ah you wake up i go get doctor
whatever your doctor mr ross how you
doing
i'm just like man you'd like to be alive
sir and i go what happened sir
well you got in a car accident my heart
just dropped like oh [ __ ]
i killed your little baby i'm like i'm
scared shitless
he goes well let's be thankful that you
didn't hit nobody but you hit the bridge
of smith park
the what yeah your body shut down
you don't remember well we have you in
icu man because your head injury was
like uh you have not been asleep in a
long time because you were so out of it
your body was so relaxed that your body
went with the your body went with the
crush
my mom took a piece of the car the hood
of the car was all metal
this much metal everything else is the
windshield
shotgun literally crushed my legs were
still extended
and the steering wheel came halfway to
my chest and that's why i fractured my
wrist
there's no the [ __ ] car demolished
you're lucky to be alive
get out of the accident recuperate go to
prison come out of prison go to itt
techtrade college
get my [ __ ] for les for let poisoning
did make something got a career job go
to san diego
do my money come back on a friday night
just spend time with my family
and spoke to why i do it his way ah
let's go the blue line to green line and
green line
about the whittier and move to downtown
l.a
spokesman do it his way i see a couple
chinese broad and a white boy oh man
they're like little swaddling little
little tipsy she had a little skirt on
and
white boy has a little you know i was
like oh man they look a little [ __ ] up
man
i'm walking over there hey are you guys
okay this brother hey
i i i got this hey you guys are hey you
guys are right hey
don't trip me i got this i mean hey is
your dad on me and they're like i don't
know what the [ __ ] this guy is
hey homie he's a grown-ass man i'm
he goes hey bro we're good and then goes
ah we're good thank you thank you so
much i appreciate it
i just want to make sure you know man
man i got this man don't try to be in my
game [ __ ]
man you ain't got [ __ ] on me walk away
this [ __ ] [ __ ] hit me behind my back
feet
home run bruce lee hit me in my [ __ ]
jaw
ricochet [ __ ] fractured the other jaw
didn't know it [ __ ] broke my
[ __ ] jaw one punch didn't know what
i'm finding this [ __ ] another
fool gets involved two people man [ __ ]
both of you [ __ ] man i go the [ __ ]
alley where my family is at
hey what's that spooky hey you guys tell
me what's wrong with my mouth man it's
[ __ ] weird my spit let me see
one lighter two lighter three letters oh
my god what what the [ __ ]
in the brothers
all right all right one lighter two
livestream five letters oh my god what
spooky one this yeah it's right here
your [ __ ] jaw's broken
for real it happened at two three
happened at two three in the morning
when this happened
you wanna call the helmet's [ __ ] no i
don't wanna be in front of no no no no
no no no no
what are you gonna do i i ain't got no
ambulance no no no no i'm [ __ ] for a
bill for me now [ __ ] that
uh i'm right here on third and fourth
street in downtown skip road
saint vincent is right off the street
you're gonna walk over there um
why not i mean i'm not i'm not crippled
i mean
well it happens that you know what let's
let's overcome the hospital right now
just give me a beer
and uh give me a bucket i kept spitting
keep spitting
drinking beer smoking crack
until [ __ ] almost five six in the
morning hey
my throat it hurts when i swallow my
shit's getting swollen your jaw's
[ __ ] broken dumbass
i don't know that though i'm just saying
metaphor speaking
you know so then hey i'm gone it's gonna
be okay don't trip i'll be okay
as i walk from [ __ ] skid row to
[ __ ] that long
tunnel in downtown lake to get to the
other side of town to go up towards
[ __ ] st
vincent i pulled him my [ __ ] my
medical card
they took their sweet ass time now my
shit's hurting my shirt's hurting bad
okay sir how can we help you my jaw's
[ __ ] broken okay what happened
i can't even [ __ ] talk then they take
me to go to a cat scan
now the cat scan oh son of a [ __ ]
they gave me a [ __ ] jacket okay lay
back
oh whoa whoa what happened you know when
you lay back your body goes back you you
i mean i'm common sense right when
you're when you lay back doesn't your
skin go back or doesn't your bones
i mean am i tripping or not but yeah
your jaw doesn't go back
so the pressure of me going back oh it
[ __ ]
hurt a guy and a girl goes no no i mean
you have to okay
if you have a broken jaw you can [ __ ]
try this [ __ ] yeah you won't do it okay
it [ __ ] hurts bad
okay but you got you know we got hey bro
you got all the tattoos [ __ ] my tattoos
my tattoo
[ __ ] my [ __ ] jaw [ __ ] you you know
you want something don't
suck it out you people don't understand
my [ __ ] jaw is [ __ ] literally
[ __ ] deformed
and you want me to lay back like through
my drone and go backwards like come on
unless you [ __ ] hurt
but i sucked it up went back
and the [ __ ] hurt like [ __ ] and with the
machine
son of my [ __ ] man they put me in my
little room
they said tomorrow when he gets results
for your [ __ ] jaw we'll give you some
morphine shots so you'd be okay marsha
the morphine shot will knock me out i'm
in jordan's hospital where my dad works
at under his nose my dad don't even know
i'm in the hospital
my dad's dead anywhere else i'm daniel
michael miles jr
everyone in the hospital don't even know
they're related five days in the
hospital
and my dad's is is the one that gets all
the supplies for the hospital on every
floor
he's been for 19 years everyone knows my
dad
i show up my dad don't know i'm right
under
how do i see my father again
that's where it gets better when i came
out of the [ __ ] house when i came out
of the cat scan
i end up you know saying that you know
we're gonna we're gonna give you the
braces we're going to shut your mouth
but staples okay
put me to sleep wake up
they put a metal plate here and a metal
plate here
what the [ __ ] i'm not [ __ ] for 10 months
eating chicken broth through a [ __ ]
straw chinese food spaghetti [ __ ] you
guys you guys are scandals here you
don't [ __ ] hungry dick oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] let's talk about torture oh
but it only gets better
my ex-girlfriend thought that i was
messing with my
homegirl jackie and my hunger for my
neighborhood
my own homegirl that i never even had
sex with
but my right eye partner my bonnie and
clyde you know i mean make that failure
you know the gangster [ __ ] you know what
i mean but i always wanted to but
you know i have a boyfriend's food you
know me but it was like so [ __ ]
intense so like you know like
when we do it we're gonna be after
change i'm loving it everybody wanna
call it let's talk about sex baby it's
shouldn't be that [ __ ]
but we never crossed that boundary out
of respect
but my ex thought that we did that we we
did the whole
sha bang bang bang bang bang boom
whatever you wanna call that [ __ ]
babe we didn't she was hungry at 2 30 in
the morning she wanted to get something
to eat
let's go get some meat let's go man she
took the [ __ ] kitchen knife out of
the kitchen
i didn't know about it we're walking in
south central
and she's bringing up the same old [ __ ]
i kept i never [ __ ] chanted what the
[ __ ] are you talk
here we go you know what i'm so sick and
tired of this [ __ ] [ __ ]
as you as i'm walking on the outside
woman's on the inside as always
i'm looking at the streets and i don't
see who's around
i wasn't even paying attention to her as
as soon as i can turn my head
[ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] liar and
standing in the back
that [ __ ] went all the way in all the
way out let alone i've never been
stabbed never been shot what the [ __ ]
you guys think about the one you love
the most so so you think
spooky what the [ __ ]
it happened so [ __ ] fast it didn't
even faze me but it's like
[ __ ] did you just [ __ ] stab me i try
to grab the knife from her hand
hell help shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ] two
three in the morning i don't know what
i'm gonna help you
i couldn't get the knife out of her hand
i let go
i walk like [ __ ] you [ __ ] as i'm
walking
walking regular but then it's a little
tipsy
a little side i'm walking north side
i see one of my brothers coming down it
was so spooky
and my boy is you know doing he's on his
own little high whatever he's looking on
the ground just you know moving his feet
around
like you know i'm trying to see if
there's anything whatever hey spooks
you're bleeding homes
it's a thin line between love and hate
he looked up
oh oh oh [ __ ] he put his arm around me
and
walked into hamburger palace right there
in south central in the parking lot
this lady was sitting without a crate
honey honey honey here let's put sit
down
i don't want to sit down on me i want to
breathe straight i don't want to bend my
left i i
want to stand up straight don't dory i
had on a
slingshot white t-shirt color t-shirt
windbreaker raider [ __ ] windbreaker i
went through all that
my homeboy is trying to tell me if i can
pick up my [ __ ] windbreaker along
with all my [ __ ] damn t-shirts and
[ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] what not
as you pick it up what does it do it
gets tighter
you're on don't don't when you pick it
up dick you're putting [ __ ] push on
my chest and it's
no just you know
who's calling who's called the ambulance
she looked at me
i looked at him after her [ __ ] had her
[ __ ]
thumb on the phone circling like should
i call
someone better [ __ ] call my [ __ ]
dad right here what the [ __ ] so then
they call spooks what are we going to
say a cracker stabbed me
just [ __ ] just get over with but the
whole time in reality when i'm doing
this [ __ ]
when i went to torrance hospital
again dad's worker his little
his little psychic partner with the you
know unload trucks or material when it
comes restocked whatever
my dad's um little psychic partner
comes in around almost like five in the
morning and this incident happened i'm
like three or four
i'm getting sent to uh torrance hospital
and my dad's partner sees me
he goes oh [ __ ] that's
daniel's son i'm back in there again
guys with the stab wound
and the nurses are like nurse yes
it's okay sir doctor yeah he's yeah we
got uh okay we're good
and then one of the nurses goes isn't
this this is this
daniel's thing no i don't know is it
they're talking and i look at the nurse
and barely speak is why
this whole time when she [ __ ] stabbed
me i'm walking regular
i'm walking like this i'm walking like
this i'm walking like this
because the blood's filling up with my
lung and i i can't i can't stand
straight because the blood's making me
go like this
nurse she goes yes yes i can't breathe
doctor he can't breathe
doctors was with my dad daddy this is
your son
yes one of the best doctors in torrance
hospital and one of the main ones been
there for years
right then we got him all i see is a
[ __ ] that little silver knife with a
little razor
oh god he goes there's there's no doctor
you can't raise
okay and then oh god no medication and
just wait
oh [ __ ] i'm just like did it hurt i i
didn't i'm like i don't know dick i'm
[ __ ] so in shock like
and they said you know i was out
wake up the [ __ ] machine going dick
dick dick i gotta carry that with me to
a little restroom
and get with you carry it with me back
what the [ __ ]
two [ __ ] two [ __ ]
you know two pipes right here
two [ __ ] two sides are [ __ ] water
holes okay
i get a phone call hello hi baby
i love you i miss you what the [ __ ] oh
my god
i married an ex-murderer what the [ __ ]
man
she has another say i said i'm sorry
[ __ ] oh my god
i don't know what you want to call that
she said she was sorry
if i allow you one more time to say that
i'm gonna knock you upside the head okay
if that's a way of saying i had to get
you no no no no
no your your reasons of your
ideas or your epiphanies or situations
that you think that you know but you
have no
strong facts only on some [ __ ] of
[ __ ] what
pregnancy hormones and emotionals you
kind of worse than that
yeah you do yeah you do you just thought
saw that pushing but just stabbed me in
the back like saying [ __ ] me
sure did that guy but guess what [ __ ]
you didn't kill me
you tried but you didn't the whole point
is
as i'm in the hospital what the [ __ ]
you're
at my uncles with my son like
nothing cause i told everyone that crack
is that i lied to my mom
i lied to my dad my stepmom my uncle my
auntie
my other uncle i lied to my whole family
but only one person in my family my
uncle the triple o g
is done time also and it doesn't sound
like spooky how the [ __ ] let someone
just come up and stab
him they don't add up right he always
you know when you say you lie or you try
a lie
but that lies like come again
yeah a crack is them okay
ah try again let's make a deal like what
the [ __ ] mango says
gina stabbed you huh [ __ ] he got it
i can't lie to my uncle i broke down
i said yeah she did that
[ __ ] she was at my house dale theo
my son i don't know but you and your
diabetes and everything and
you're getting hype you know i don't
need you to [ __ ] your [ __ ] up don't
don't trip don't trip just let me
recuperate
i don't okay but my son i don't want my
son
he told me okay i'll relax what do you
want me to do
let it play itself out let me figure it
out okay just let me figure it out okay
i will
he went back to the house oh the like
you know
that my uncle could not hold it
he couldn't hold it how dare you i
invite you to my house
what are you talking about reuben and
all the innocent what my nephew told me
okay never told you what okay and then
that you [ __ ] stabbed him [ __ ]
uh
i don't need to hear this [ __ ] she wants
to get up and pack up her bags and leave
here we go with the [ __ ] you're not
leaving a monkey yes i am
oh no my phone rings in my room oh [ __ ]
hello
i just told you ruben do not
my own uncle made it more worse okay
let her go what can you do as
she was leaving cory called the cops
and the cops told reuben do you
want to press charges for what
for what she did to your nephew i guess
my nephew's in the hospital right now
he's on the phone hello morales
yes and whatever you want to call it you
know my life
my life wasn't threatened my life was
almost taken
by a kitchen steak knife goes all the
way in you all the way out like nothing
and be okay you got me [ __ ] up it
turned out to be that uh
yeah she did stab me yes detaches came
in my room
and they says that uh one unit went one
direction
couldn't find her other unit got her
walking down 87th and avalon trying to
do a side street they got her
we have her in custody along with your
son
social service is going to come get
mikey out of there
so you want to press charges
i'll solve the deadly weapon yes
so as i recuperate from the hospital
and go back to
my living i have my son with me
you know i made a father taking care of
my son
again knock on the door yeah says
michael morales here
michael morales that's my son yes we
have a warrant right here
what we're here to take mikey from you
because she said that i hit her
[ __ ] domestic violence
so she goes out with a bang and my son
gets taken from me with all
multiple officers right there can i
escort him to the car seat yes you can
i got a little bag ready i was in tears
her cousin lives in san bernardino
her cousin has a good life she works
real estate
my son's taken care of my son's a little
gq little boy he's a little commercial
baby he really is
uh you know if i could show on next
video for future reference i will show
you a picture of him
he's a handsome little boy commercial
babe i guarantee you that
but um if i could say
at least my son's in good hands i can
only give the benefit of the doubt that
he's taken care of
what can i do for him when i'm trying to
get myself
situated not let things put me down or
you know bring myself up it's a lot of
work it's not easy
but uh when she went to jail
for assault with deadly weapon
and a strike when social services came
to my house
and they seen the kitchen knife
oh no no no let me take a picture of
this [ __ ] that's a murder weapon
what took a picture of the judge from
assault with a deadly weapon to a
attempted murder with a strike
four months five months pregnant and got
released
four [ __ ] months in a strike
if it was me i would not be having this
video with you guys right now
i'll be doing live after my third strike
let alone what she got out of four
months
[ __ ] [ __ ] put me on facebook spooky
from west side orphans to snitch in a
rat
facebook dick i just left a high level
yard [ __ ] i don't have a high
level yard
with respect and she wants to say i'm a
you don't think there's
someone out there i'll do it i'll do it
i'll do it i gotta
you don't think so for what the [ __ ] oh
spooky let it go
oh i'm gonna beat your referee saying
that you think that i'm not
in this to [ __ ] win you think i'm
gonna say oh half step
people get together homie that's a
[ __ ]
i don't know what it's real serious when
it comes to situations like that you
know my life's at stake
if i show any envy or any that's your
mother your kids i don't give a [ __ ]
when i know i'm not a snitch i know i'm
not a rat and you label me as that
you gotta go the [ __ ]
but uh i don't like ugly god
as her i don't know where she's at i
don't give a [ __ ] where she's at but uh
i guess that's a small world i just
leave it at that but um
when all in all when i just think that
stab wound that's a wrap
a couple months after that i'm on a
beach cruiser from sunday
afternoon gonna go downtown l.a from
south central 87th street
all the way down avalon to 7th street
going you know go see my camaradas and
[ __ ]
i left that bum like 10 9 9 10 in the
morning
going down avalon at my own bike lane my
jbl
riding you know i'm just doing my own
thing
avalon jefferson before i hit jefferson
a car i don't know how the [ __ ]
this is my own bike lane the gap and the
car lane for their [ __ ] section
how the [ __ ] can you come all over here
hit me from behind
whoa i see some [ __ ] just like just
spin
[Music]
the jbl goes one way i go with it
if i could go under the [ __ ] car and
the [ __ ] wheel is [ __ ] dragging me
and hitting me [ __ ] like this they're
just burning me
oh what the [ __ ] and then a mile and a
half it spits me out the [ __ ] car
what the [ __ ] just happened my speaker
goes rumbling rumbling
and my [ __ ] if you can see i don't
know if you can see the little you know
little den in my head but
blood just gushing down somebody help me
can someone help me okay okay the blood
is getting
low like this like this is getting
bigger son of a [ __ ]
hey bro you okay i'm looking with one
eye like this
[ __ ] you know resonate kind of guy
[ __ ] five
six five five whatever he's looking left
and right
he's saying what the [ __ ] did i create
[ __ ] fool got back in the car and
boned out all right
i hit him run i get they call the
ambulance
i guess at the general hospital from 10
30
got discharged at 4 30 the same day no
paperwork
no medication bandage wrapped around my
head
cleaned me up a little bit because for
the fact that they
did they did a cat scan on me no
fracture skull
no broken bones no stitches no
neck brace but two layers of skin off
his head
and a [ __ ] road rash on his back like
ouch
get the [ __ ] out of here
ladies and gentlemen and all my life
from a child to a teenager to an adult
this is death number 10 for me
what is my reason here for living i want
answers
sometimes god does everything
within itself on its own terms when the
time is ready but if people see
like you people out there and you know
worldwide that
see something in me of talent potential
kobe bryant all that you know you people
don't even
know of me but only what i share with
you of my lifestyle
i thank you guys for just like
encouraging me to
never give up my hopes and dreams have
faith have hope
stay strong so we all live long
but if i'm here for a reason
i know god put me for a testimony to be
something you know
but uh i'm here today thank god
you know that's not my time if i'm here
for a reason
i want to be there to help anyone that
needs help you know what i'm saying
we all do love you guys man god bless
you guys
thanks spooky
you're a great speaker really